a belief in God is among the most common
religious beliefs held by Americans nine
and ten Americans report believing God
or the universal spirit however
perspectives on God are incredibly
varied and doubts about God's existence
are far more prevalent among the public
than typically thought that's about God
vary considerably by religious tradition
and three groups really stand out white
evangelical Protestants black
Protestants and Mormons in contrast
Jewish Americans are far less certain in
their views of God there's also a great
deal of uncertainty among the
non-religious while 71% of atheists feel
completely certain God does not exist
more than one-quarter expressed some
amount of doubt there are also stark
divides when it comes to age gender and
political affiliation young adults
expressed more doubt about God than
older Americans and conservatives are
far more certain in their beliefs than
liberals despite these differences when
it comes to religious belief daddy may
be the one thing that unites believers
and non-believers how certain are you
that God exists let us know in our poll
also let us know what other topics you'd
like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds
and be sure to LIKE and subscribe for
more research and videos from AEI